[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ian rappaport national
insider for nfl network nfl.com
joins us from the buccaneers camp and
tampa is in jacksonville
yesterday miami tomorrow busy man and
carving out a couple of minutes for us
ian what did you learn today from bruce
aryans
i learned uh that bruce aryans
worked his team like they didn't win a
super bowl it was actually really
interesting because
there's a couple things i kind of want
and you have to excuse me i'm walking
where i'm gonna have to go to
tv in like two minutes these guys are
about to kill me over here
um i learned that bruce aryans
is not worried about a super bowl
hangover because all he wanted to do
was beat the blank out of his players in
a very nice way football way of course
but they certainly are not certainly are
not working
like they just won the super bowl and
they're kind of happy i also learned
that tom brady is still a very good
football player though he did not
practice today
sounds like he has looked as excellent
as you would imagine
some other things but i would say those
are probably the main points there
can you uh help us handicap what's going
to happen with the colts
yeah i mean so a couple things the
window for whence
five to 12 weeks that is a long window
that probably means he's going to miss
the opener
it probably also means he's back before
september is over
probably so i don't get the feeling
they're going to trade for anyone it
feels like they're going to go with
jacob eason
she ever once is in his rehab if things
are real real slow
maybe they'll reevaluate but it didn't
feel to me like this is a team that's
going to be real real active in the
trademark and it felt to me like this is
a team
that's confident in the guy that they
drafted
and wants to move forward with him
that's kind of the sense that
rather than you know go trade for nick
foles or trade for gardner-mintu or
someone like that
when do we find out something with
desean watson when does the nfl have to
say something or the texan say something
because i mean he's been cleared to
practice
well he's and he's not practicing today
um i
it seems like a minor minor injury issue
for deshaun watson obviously getting
you know playing fourth safety um
something that you know dinged him up
pretty good
um so he's you know minor injury not
practicing today and
uh we'll see uh we'll see how long this
lasts it's a little bit of a i would say
a fascinating injury situation
uh with the houston texans yeah i just
wonder about that though
at some point they have to make a
decision commissioner's exempt list or
whatever
it's going to be um yeah but
commissioner's exempt list is not going
to be until there's games at stake
yeah so um
it's the weird murkiness is going to
continue for the foreseeable future and
i have no idea when it's going to end i
just know
of all the things they're looking for
answers for there are no answers like
his case is not he's not even going to
be deposed until probably february yeah
um so it's going to be continued to be
incredibly you need me right now
it's going to continue to be incredibly
murky dan i really apologize
um i'm being called on no worries no
worries
i am thank you for adjusting and and
um i owe you a beer next time i see you
in person i really apologize
no worries no worries thank you ian we
appreciate it thanks dan
that's ian rappaport national insider
big tv guy he's on
nfl network